la búsqueda ahora se centra en detectar
con precisión los sonidos clave que
permitirían dar con la ubicación del
sumergible perdido en las profundidades
del Atlántico Norte aviones canadienses
detectaron ruidos submarinos Cuando el
reloj marcaba las últimas 24 horas para
hallar a las cinco personas a bordo del
submarino desaparecido los sonidos de
baja frecuencia se empezaron a repetir
cada 30 minutos en lo que expertos
identificaron que eran golpes similares
a los de una estructura metálica capaces
de subir hasta la superficie sin embargo
la propagación acústica no es muy buena
y aunque los ruidos dan Esperanza el
sumergible todavía enfrenta muchas
amenazas en las profundidades del océano
este submarino según la información
disponible cuenta con un sistema que
detecta cualquier daño en su casco es
muy importante aquí que nos hagamos la
idea de la presión externa la que está
sometida es un elemento sobre el que hay
una presión por todas sus partes de
equivalente a 380 atmósferas que es lo
que tendríamos a la altura del mar
cualquier mínimo daño perforación del
casco
cualquier
milimétrico defecto en cualquiera de sus
elementos lo que provoca es una
implosión la profundidad y el lugar
donde pueda estar la nave es otro de los
obstáculos
hay dos profundidades en las que podría
estar a 3.800 metros o a 0 no creo que
esté en medio Así que si está a 3.800
metros esto significa que algo grave
sucedió y no han podido liberar el plomo
pesado que le daría de 4 a 500 kilos de
flotabilidad y les permitiría subir a la
superficie
se espera que un robot francés que puede
sumergirse a 6000 metros bajo el agua
ayuda en la búsqueda que tiene como
límite del jueves cuando se tiene
estimado que se agote el suministro de
aire del sumergible perdido